Good morning Hank, it's Tuesday.
I was duly awed by your epic and encyclopedic
rant about punishments.
And so, even though I still believe in my
heart that I do not owe a punishment, I'm
going to do one because data does not lie.
Well, sometimes it does, but it lies less
than your heart.
That's what today's video is kind of about,
actually.
Okay, Hank, so my favorite character in this
summer's Book Club pick, "Behind the Beautiful
Forevers", is Sunil the twelve-year-old garbage
picker who grew up in an orphanage, in fact
we're told,
"Though Sunil was not an orphan, he understood
that phrases like 'AIDS orphan', and 'when
I was the second hand woman to Mother Teresa'
helped Sister Paulette, the nun who ran the
Handmaids of the Blessed Trinity Children's
Home, get money from foreigners."
By the way, little recommendation, when you
have a four-year-old child, don't take books
to the beach.
So anyway, that's the first mention of charity
in Behind the Beautiful Forevers, and boy,
is it complicated.
Sunil is a non-orphan in an orphanage, Sister
Paulette lies to raise money, and we later
read that when the orphanage collects clothes
for the kids and then sells those clothes
to pay for other stuff.
But while Sunil isn't an orphan, he does need
the orphanage.
Plus, he learns to read while he's there.
And that's the kind of non-straightforward
story about charities, both domestic and international,
that we rarely hear, especially from charities
themselves.
Right, because they have to raise money, and
telling people,
"Ah, we think this is going to go well, it
isn't going to be perfect, but we suspect
it will be a net-positive, although there's
no way to know", that's a terrible fundraising
strategy.
But that's closer to the reality that we see
in Behind the Beautiful Forevers, like the
charity-administered school in Annawadi is
taught by a teenager and definitely sub-standard.
And toward the end of the book we learn that
many charity-administered schools are outright
frauds.
When a new school opened in the Pink Temple
by the sewage lake, many children gravitated
to it.
But it closed as soon as the leader of the
non-profit had taken enough pictures of children
studying to secure government funds.
And then there are, like, collaborations between
government and charity, which are also sometimes
problematic.
Like, you'll remember that Annawadi's political
representative who is super corrupt keeps
getting public amenities, care of the charity
World Vision.
You know, like public toilets and gutters
etcetera, and that's all good stuff, but it's
timed to the elections so that he can keep
his power.
And so you could see it as these projects
like further institutionalizing the corrupt
power system, right.
But then again, good toilets are really important
for public health.
It's complicated.
Hank, this is all particularly interesting
to me right now because, as you watch this,
I am in East Africa learning about some of
the work that people there are doing with
the help of the Gates Foundation.
Now, the situation in East Africa is vastly
different from the situation in Annawadi,
but around the world, including in our own
neighborhoods, we need to look at what charities
do and how well they do it.
Hank, you don't want to be giving to charity
simply because it makes you feel good or because
it lessens some guilt that you have.
We want to actually decrease World Suck.
I apologize for splitting that infinitive
but I felt that it was necessary.
When we talk about health and poverty, we
are talking about incredibly complicated problems
and yes, money can be misallocated, and it
can be used to bolster corrupt regimes, but
we have lots of data -- links in the doobly-doo
-- showing that in the last twenty years,
when people have access to the right resources
and tools, they can transform the health and
economic opportunities in their communities.
Rising income, better food security, higher
literacy rates, lower infant mortality -- those
aren't anecdotes and they are real progress.
Hank, one of the reasons I continue to reread
"Behind the Beautiful Forevers" is that it
doesn't contain any unambiguous victories.
Not for the characters, certainly, but also
not for foreign aid or government spending
or microfinance or charity.
Non-profit spending doesn't always work, partly
because not all non-profits are equally effective
and partly because no one succeeds all of
the time.
I think when trying to figure out what does
work, data is probably ultimately a better
guide than anecdote.
But then again, data can also be manipulated.
Hank, we are either going to embrace complexity
or we're going to be lying to ourselves.
That's what I took away from "Behind the Beautiful
Forevers".
I look forward to reading your thoughts in
comments when I return.
Hank, I hope to learn a lot this week, and
I hope to listen a lot, but if I come home
with straightforward answers and simple solutions,
I am probably doing it wrong.
Okay Hank, although I will be very jet-lagged,
I will see you on Friday.